madison to news now from carson city
lawmakers are in a special session in
the capitol to discuss redistricting the
main bill passed out of the committee
today and now moves on to the senate
floor republicans and minority groups
have largely opposed it several senators
say the bill may be changed as it moves
forward to reflect testimony from
today's hearing review journal political
editor steve sebelius spoke on how this
year will differ from the process 10
years ago
so the democrats can ignore those
republican maps knowing that in whatever
they produce is very likely going to be
signed by governor sisolak who's also a
democrat it's not like 10 years ago
where the democrats passed their maps
and a republican governor vetoed those
maps and the matter went to court
republicans aren't happy with the
democratic bill's districting lines and
minority groups feel that if the
democratic lines are drawn that will
dilute their voting power if this does
pass all the way through political
analysts say that will have a big impact
for the upcoming 2022 election